[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud L proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
Jim I don't report sex Grimes Jordan
will he become Jim I can't win the
speakership Jordan again
today oh boy all the winning that these
Republicans do isn't it just glorious oh
my God all the winning we're going to
win so much you get a win you get a win
you get a
win it's always like opposite day with
these [__] ain't it oh my God
Jim Jordan loses
yesterday gets torn apart he lost he
lost worse than what Kevin mcth than
what Kevin McCarthy's vote was to vacate
like the House Republicans like Kevin
McCarthy more than they like Jim Jordan
so that means they got rid of a speaker
because he did his job bare minimum did
his job and kept the government open at
the LA very last [__] second Kevin
McCarthy and they they got rid of him
and they're goingon to put someone who's
less popular to to their group to their
caucus than than the guy who did his job
and kept the government open by working
with Democrats by the way Democrats did
that they're not doing this though this
is not of Democrats doing they can't get
enough Republicans to vote for a speaker
now today's going to another day uh
where we're watching the house floor and
to be honest Tom Cole is on the house
floor right now so let's listen in Tom
Cole tell lies about Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan let's hear it let's he
move legislation that would meaningfully
deal with this problem and this my
friends on both sides of the ey but with
all due respect particularly this
Administration and my friends on the
other side need to look at this oh yeah
it's all our fault it's all our fault
immigration seriously you ain't going to
have immigration reform until we have
border security what the [__] are you
talking about dude you can't even select
a speaker Tom Cole shut the [__] up shut
the [__] up that can bring us together
there are a lot of things we disagree on
legitimately so almost everything most
of us do not disagree about the security
of the state of Israel all well I don't
I don't know about that I don't know you
guys can't can't seem to get a leader
together you really don't give a [__]
about our national security what makes
us believe you care about their
reacted with
horror and with deep sympathy and with
legitimate outrage at the crime that was
perpetrated against the people of Israel
in the last week all of us and all of us
know that they are
within
L to defend our people and punish those
who brought that upon
[Applause]
them so at a moment of Crisis and we are
in a moment of Crisis yeah because you
created
we speak we know we can't do that
without a speaker of the house yeah it
would be nice if you guys knew that
weeks ago and I are in the
majority uh and we need produce a
speaker that is your job we have a
candidate who we know where he will
stand on issues important we definitely
know he will close his eyes when his
student athletes are being sexually
molested in a shower for sure I know
what he's going to do on the board you
godamn right you know what he's going to
soltion it's not just money it's policy
and change that will provide security
for the American people and finally and
I say this on a bipartisan basis oh I'm
sure I know he will stand up for Israel
and I know in that area he wouldn't even
protect his students what makes you
think he's going to protect Americans
and Israelis get a request almost any
time to act we need to be able to act my
friend will act on that crisis he's
shown it so
he he acts never I have the privilege
Nom to be a [__] clown our chairman
of the Judiciary Committee but a person
whose principles you know whose actions
you can trust and who in a time of
Crisis the exact opposite of the truth
these people I'm telling you
what [__] isn't it
rich isn't it [__] Rich holy good
godamn well I told you today was going
to be a special day today and if you're
tuning in here you're watching the house
floor now from cpan that's right I'm
ripping off spe cpan [__]
them Mr agalar is going to speak on
behalf of the Democrats and he is going
to nominate hakee Jeff here and I my
guess is aing Jeff is going to win the
popular vote again that that is going to
be absolutely 100% what is going to
happen uh because Democrats are a party
that wants to govern and they understand
to govern you have to have a leader and
they understand that that when you pick
a leader you must pick a leader that
everyone can get behind no matter how
how your ideology Lies when you're in a
party and you're in and you're in a
majority or you're in a caucus you have
to select leadership that you can
follow the problem is is that the GOP
the Clowns the clown
caucus the clown car is empty for them
to select speaker and the only only one
they have left is Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan and again today maybe his
new nickname will be Jim I can't win my
speakership Jordan what a bunch of
[__] losers what a bunch of [__]
clowns and there's only one reason why
all this is happening anyways folks only
one
reason because the head clown the master
clown the Maga King is the Puppet Master
here that's why Donald Trump controls
them Lock Stock and
Barrel there's no other thing that you
need to know then Donald Trump controls
the Republican House of Representatives
majority period he controlled Kevin
McCarthy how in the [__] how in the [__]
do you think that Kevin McCarthy became
speaker
anyways because Donald Trump backed him
because Kevin McCarthy was willing going
to trade away his entire speakership to
Donald Trump now the media wants to
spend it as oh well there's a Maga
caucus inside the house that is
controlling the moderates no it's Donald
Trump's minions who he controls in the
house that are controlling Our House of
Representatives this is an authoritarian
party period they are Nazis that is how
authoritarian authoritarianism
Works get it right right in your [__]
heads this is not some something that
you do that we can't see right out in
front of us do you think that Jim how
many phone calls do you think Jim Jordan
has received from Donald Trump since the
time he lost yesterday until this
morning that they're on the house floor
right now how many how many [__]
dozens of times do you think Trump has
called losing his [__] ever loving
mind trying to figure out why the
soldiers won't get in line line and he
can't figure it out because he's a dumb
Dum he's an idiot he doesn't know that
there's 18 [__] seats that are in
Biden districts that Biden not only is
Biden going to win in those districts
but he's going to swing to the Democrats
or at least attempt it's up to you to
help him to help him do
that and that's where the 20 plus comes
from the other reason why is because the
person that Donald Trump is endorsing is
a [__] scumbag not only is he a
scumbag he's a lazy piece of trash Jim
Jordan I don't know if you know or
watched him hold a hearing as the
chairman but he is a [__] Darick
[__] Jim Jordan is Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan and for Tom
Cole to stand on the house floor and say
that Jim Jordan somehow is a hard worker
what what the [__] are you talking about
what he acts he says Tom Cole says he
acts he does he acts like he's working
he sure [__] does act like he's
working act like he's working by taking
off his jacket and rolling up his
sleeves oh boy Jim Jordan must work a
lot because he's got his sleeves rolled
up but if you've ever watched him be a
chairman of a house Committee
hearing you know that Jim Jordan is a
worthless piece of [__]
worthless piece of [__] [__] Jim
Jordan
is he can't he has no idea of the rules
he has no idea how to make a Committee
hearing work he has no idea how to run
the room they never ever ever future
proof anything they say or do they have
no clue that Democrats are really
[__] good at at questions and
controlling a committee room no [__]
clue that Daniel Goldman that Crockett
that
AOC that
moscowitz I mean the list goes on and on
and on of Representatives on the
Democratic side that absolutely [__]
dunk these stupid idiots MAA idiots in
the [__] trash every single
time absolutely oblivious to it because
the only thing they care about the only
thing you want you don't want to know
what Jim Jordan works really [__]
hard at do you know what he works really
[__] hard at oh man he gets up in the
morning and this is all he [__]
thinks about it's all he dreams about is
his little moment on Fox News the little
clip that they're gonna put on Fox news
of Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
just own in the libs baby oh he works
really hard really [__] hard to to
act like he's owning the
libs and this is their leadership that
they are looking to folks
good [__] them listen I don't want Jim
Jordan anywhere near a congressional
seat Jim Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan shouldn't even be the goddamn dog
catcher in his [__] District if you
want to know the God's honest
truth but here we are because MAA is a
bunch of [__] [__] eaters they
believe anything that they're told
they'll do anything and they will fall
in line because they are brainless
morons and they will vote for people
like Jim Jordan they will vote for
people like Donald Trump they will vote
for people like Lauren bobert and
margorie Taylor green and Matt gats and
Jim Jim comr and every single [__]
Republican out there that is not a
serious
person they are not serious people they
are not serious policy makers they do
not give a [__] about you they do not
give a [__] about your District they do
not give a [__] about your family the
econom
they don't give a [__] about you they
only [__] care about their own power
and they only care about their donor's
[__] money
period
period they can care less what you think
they could care less what you need they
could care less how you want the country
to operate they don't give a
[__] and that's why we are where we are
right now in this point and you know
what it's going to be a hard pill the
swallow but we got to let these
Republicans [__]
fail we have to let them
fail because when they fail the country
will see that they fail and we must
point it out over and over and over and
over
again maybe just
maybe that enough Americans will have
still enough brain cells to rub together
to create some energy to get off their
[__] ass and go put adults in
charge in 2024 now I'm very confident
that that's going to
happen but we must not stop we must lean
into democracy we must engage in our
democracy it is super important that we
do
that without that we have
nothing
nothing no government no representation
nothing you might as well take our whole
way of life and throw it in the goddamn
trash because that's what these people
want to do and that's what they will do
because Jim Jordan is going to lose on
another ballot right it's going to be
live on this show he's going to lose
they've already started the county
here's the counting if you want to see
it here's the couny
here there's already one that has voted
against Jim Jordan because you don't
have to look at the Democrats column
because they're all going to vote for
Hakeem
Jeff that's just how it's going to
be the category the the the place you
need to be looking here is others um I
believe their Quorum is 4:30 today
there's supposed to be one Democrat
missing I believe um really that's not
going to matter I think they need 27
still if if you're out there and you and
you know those if you can if you could
put them in the chat there that way we
can see um what what those facts are so
we can keep track of this because I
don't have the math I'll I'll be quite
honest with you when I was setting up
the show I did not have the math uh
Snowden says it's four it's
4 432 uh we're at others votes too so
far my guess is is that we're going to
probably as long as we get the four NOS
Jim Jordan is not going to be the the
speaker I believe is it four or is it
three we're at three now I believe it's
four that is going to happen so uh we'll
see exactly how this is going to fall
but you know what we don't need to see
how it's G to
fall we don't need to
see we don't need to see how it's gonna
fall I'm going to tell you how it's
going to fall Jim Jordan is going to
lose again and again again and again and
again and again you know I'm honestly
not out of I don't think it's out of the
realm of
possibility that Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan isn't the speaker by the
time the government
closes and I'm not sure if there was any
um talk today rather they would keep the
floor open but what an embarrassment if
they will keep the floor open to keep
voting now you remember Kevin McCarthy
keeping the floor open open over and
over and over again voting over and over
and over it's [__] ridiculous what a
waste of time what a waste what a waste
of our country's energy to be quite
honest just what a [__] waste of
space these Republicans
are it's absolutely [__] gross but
you know what I and I know I know I know
a lot of people out there keep saying
well we can't have Jim or Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan as Speaker
there's no way we can have him as
Speaker it just can't happen
we can't let this happen there's no way
it can happen on and on and on it goes
but again folks when the when your kid
is in the kitchen and they've asked over
and over and over and over again to
touch the hot stove and every time they
reach for it you slap their hand away
you slap their hand away
eventually eventually you're gonna have
to let them touch that [__]
stove you're just gonna have to let them
do
it so they know it's
hot so they know it's hot uh some people
are saying in the chat there's four
votes again my feed is a little behind
now but we'll we'll pull it up here so
that folks that aren't watching it that
are watching the show here I can watch
there's the fourth vote there uh looks
like it was let's see who it was here
you can see the the subtitles on the
screen there too as long as they keep
going the the the C-SPAN feed is not as
uh it's not the best feed in the world
like it drags down my computer and all
kinds of [__] um someone changed their
vote from Jordan to Byron
Donald's oh my God so now they're back
on the Byron Donald's train
apparently oh son of a [__] what a
bunch of [__] clowns what a circus
this
is what a circus the American people
elected Republicans to go to Washington
to to elect a speaker and have a
majority for two [__] years and they
can't even do the bare minimum and when
the speaker does the bare minimum to
keep the government open even after he
reneges on his deal his handshake deal
with the Democrats the Democrats swoop
in and save them at the very last moment
what do they do for a speaker to do the
bare minimum trust me when I say this
folks trust me when I say this getting a
45 day SE are passed to keep the
government open for 45 days is the bare
minimum of a speaker's job bare [__]
minimum there is not much more that H
work that has to be done below a 45 day
CR besides them pretending that they're
getting rid of IRS agents like they did
passing stupid [__] bills that are
not only dead in our rival at the Senate
but Dead on Arrival on Joe Biden's
desk these people are not serious people
now I know all Democrats aren't exactly
what you want to have right like again I
I I'm gonna we're we're gonna go through
this education of what ideology is right
because I mean I have a certain ideology
you have a certain ideology our
ideologies may not be exactly the same
that's okay that's okay but most the
time your ideology fits in one party or
the other and right now you're either
like for democracy or you're not you
want to kill it like so that's the
ideology like oh I want a king so I I I
love be some Trump God Trump's God and
he's God and I love God and God loves me
and God saved Trump and they you know
they part of the cult right
authoritarians are ultimately going to
be part of the Republican and Trump cult
whereas other people who have anything
other than that ideology end up being
like well I guess I got to vote for
Democrats I don't know what else to do
or you could vote for RFK
[Laughter]
Jr oh my God have you seen the news
about this son of a [__] man son of a
[__] RFK why we're watching the house
floor here why we watching Jim Jordan
lose magnificently
again
um the rep Republicans are absolutely in
full [__] freakout mode and the
reason why they're in full freakout mode
at RFK Jr is because these [__] polls
that are coming out are showing and
they're [__] folks don't believe any of
these polls don't believe what they say
do not believe what they say now they
may be correct because a broken watch a
broken
clock a broken alarm clock a it's right
twice a day okay it's right twice said
hey so the polls can be correct but
don't believe that [__] just because it
just because they're [__] spoon
feeding that [__] to
you but maanga believes polls oh my God
they believe polls and nothing could be
better for our situation for them to
believe the [__] polls right I mean
because really the [__] polls are
really telling them all kinds of lies to
get them excited and when they get
excited they get
disengaged they get totally disengaged
Ed when they're like yeah Trump's going
to win here no no way he can lose did
you see the crowd size there's no way he
can
lose he thinks you need an i to buy
bread there's no way he could
lose it's really dangerous for them but
the other thing that's [__] dangerous
as
[__] the other thing that's totally
[__]
dangerous is that they believe polls
about RFK because they're in full freak
out mode man because the thing is here's
the thing is now they're in a situation
right uh let's go back to the house for
because now there's seven votes so Jim
Jordan has officially lost if this
Remains the count if you're following
along I was correct oh Tony's right oh
why is Tony right all the time oh my God
Tony's correct again it's almost like he
has a crystal ball or some
[__] n it's pretty easy this is all
predictably unpredictable and when
you're watching the media and you're
watching the news and you're watching
these reporters these especially these
beat reporters these days which normally
it's not that way I'm gonna get back to
the RFK thing I promise but normally the
beat reporters inside the capital
actually give you an insight to um the
inner inner politics and give you a good
insight into what's going to happen but
they they're all it's all [__]
[__] they're just doing it for
Ratings they're trying to [__] get
you all riled up about this look
Republicans don't want a speaker I don't
know if you know this but the manga part
of the party does not want a speaker and
if they want a speaker they want a
speaker that's going to do their bidding
and what I mean by that is Trump's
bidding it's an authoritarian party
that's what they want now a lot of
Republicans inside the conference don't
know that they're in an authoritarian
party that's the dumbest dog [__] part
about all this is they really don't
realize that Donald Trump is controlling
their concus and the only way forward
for them to be a serious politician is
to leave the Republican party period
that's the only way that's it that's the
only way for them for them to do this
there's eight defectors
now uh in the Republican caucus here so
there's bound to be more I would imagine
we're going to get very close to 20
again it's probably going to be 18 to 22
uh defectors because once he's lost
there's no reason for someone to take a
vote for Jim Jordan that's the other
thing that they that's the other reason
why I'm telling you he's going to lose
and lose lose and lose and lose and lose
and lose and lose and lose and lose and
lose and lose and lose and lose the
reason why is because once they have
enough defection why the [__] would you
vote for a guy who looked the other way
when his student athletes were [__]
being molested let alone tried to be the
engineer of the coup attempt to try to
overturn our government this guy wants
to be the speaker of our government and
he was working with Donald Trump to
overt
it Jesus [__] Christ people it's not
hard to understand these things it's not
hard to understand this and most of the
time I'm talking Daga when I'm saying
that [__] because they're just stay
ain't got no [__] brain cells realize
what the hell's going on in front of
them I understand my audience is well
educated and they like to educate
themselves not just educate themselves
on the facts but educate themselves on
contemporaneous issues it's very
important that you stay up with I don't
know the news of the day so you can vote
accordingly and that's what we have to
do we have to pound this in people's
heads that yes the Republicans are derel
in their Duty it's now up to nine oh my
God and someone's saying 10 now again it
it my fe's just a bit behind so it's if
you're not watching the vote again it's
boring
[__] I'll get back to the ARF G thing
here in just a second why them believing
the polls and talking about the [__] is
make gon to make it even worse on
them here's the
thing what say are so many [__]
thoughts uh my feed is behind uh but
here's the thing government is boring
it's supposed to be [__]
boring okay like literally it is
supposed to be boring that's the whole
point of government it's not supposed to
be this [__] big show this reality TV
show that's why the Republicans have a
really tough time too governing because
they spend 98% of their time doing the
reality show 1% of their time having
cocaine sex orgies and the other one%
thinking about doing serious government
not doing it just thinking about it do
you follow me 98% is a reality show 1%
is the cocaine sex orches actually that
may be like 10 11% I might be really
misjudging this that may be more like
30% if I'm going to be completely honest
you know what I mean so it's like 69%
reality show 30% cocaine sex orgies and
then like 1% them actually sitting down
and thinking about maybe we should
actually do some work today I don't know
maybe we should do that but government
is supposed to be serious all the time
which most of the time if you ever met a
really serious person that takes
themselves way too seriously they're
[__] boring have you ever listened to
NPR oh my God that [__] is [__]
boring as hell are you kidding me why
would you go
listen welcome to the Tony Michael's
podcast uh today we're going to be
looking at the house L we're going to be
keeping track of all the votes and Jim
Jordan the representative from Ohio the
the the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee is going to be nominated for
speaker of the house uh right now we see
that there is 12 votes in the other
category and Jim Jeff you see what I
mean it's [__] boring it's boring
because they take themselves too [__]
seriously it's the whole point stop
taking yourselves too seriously but the
problem is is now the unserious people
are the ones in charge that's not what
we want that it's not that's not what we
want we do not we the clowns are
supposed to be clowning that's what I am
yes yes maanga I'm the clown look Tony's
calling himself a clown well if you
don't know that by now then you you
you're being
duped because you're being clowned by
the clowns to think that they're the
serious people that you should put in
charge to do the serious things and
they're not serious these people are not
[__]
serious and that is why the Republicans
have such trouble oh we're up to a dozen
woohoo 12 so far Jim Jordan is a [__]
loser bam bam bam I wonder how many
times he's gonna actually do this today
I would guess only one why the [__]
would he do this more than once today
really would you do that to yourself
think about this if you got up in the
morning you had your cup of coffee and
then you had to punch yourself in the
face as hard as you could like literally
like in the mirror too you're looking in
the mirror and you just got to [__]
punch yourself in the face as hard as
you can would you do it more than once
if you didn't have
to I mean would you I wouldn't [__]
punch myself more in the face than I had
to at least in one day I mean this is so
stupid he's not going to have the votes
today he's not going to have the votes
tomorrow he's not going to have them on
on Friday he's not going to have them
next week that's the point they're not
he listen to me listen to me when I tell
you this Republicans are not gonna have
the votes for Jim Jordan anytime
soon they're not and it's because he is
Jim
Jordan but it's because Donald Trump has
handpicked him and because Donald Trump
is controlling the house of Republicans
no one else wants to be speaker no one
no even Jim Jordan doesn't want to be
speaker if you want to know the honest
truth Jim Jordan doesn't want to be
speaker it's going to ruin it it's going
to ruin his cushy job he doesn't do [__]
are you kidding me this [__]
gets up in the morning can't even put a
jacket on right can't even put a jacket
on to go to [__] work he barely ties
his tie and just enough time to [__]
roll up his sleeve to act like he's
working as Tom coleos he acts he acts
Jim Jordan acts yeah he sure does
Act
he acts a
lot but he's acting like he's working
why why the [__] would Jim Jordan want
to be speaker and ruin his congressional
seat that's what he's going to do if you
become speaker I don't know if you know
this but all
all of the of the last Republican
speakers have been nothing but [__]
dumpster fires and it ruins their
careers Kevin McCarthy will not be a a
representative from Bakersfield very
soon he
won't he won't
it ruins them absolutely [__] ruins
them the only reason why Kevin McCarthy
has not relinked with his seat in shame
already is because there are there are
some in the house that still think they
may need ha to have Kevin McCarthy
available to be
speaker I'm not [__] you I wouldn't
[__] you you're my favorite turd there's
no way that they're keeping Kevin
McCarthy for other than that that they
think maybe just maybe Kevin McCarthy
that masochist is the only one that'll
step in to be speaker because they're
going to have to have one at some point
there's even talk to make the Elf on the
Shelf Patrick McKenry some kind of
[__] uh acting speaker where they
give him more power because really the
the speaker protim all they have the
power to do is open the floor and vote
for speaker because they don't have one
that's the [__]
rules that's the [__] rules when you
set the rules you got to go by the rules
so either they go by the rules and they
keep voting because that's the thing
they have to when they open the floor
they have to call Quorum for vote and
then they have to vote for speaker
that's how it
works that's how it works here's here's
here's the the count again it's 13 it
might be higher than this now 13 but you
know it doesn't matter Jim Jordan's
already lost again uh we're going to
keep track of this thing today
too when when when the final count comes
and Patrick McHenry I'll try to get him
up on air uh live and then what they'll
do is he'll announce the vote and blah
blah blah and then he'll call for recess
and they'll say I and they'll recess
because Democrats don't give a [__]
Democrats are definitely going to recess
this thing they don't care [__] yeah
more days of them losing H let's do that
let's do that more days of Republicans
making fools out of themselves fine
let's do that are you [__] me this
is the best [__] entertainment ever
if you're if you're a liberal if you're
on the left at all or if you just don't
like Republicans at this point which if
you don't like Republicans at this point
you need to gather up a few more brain
cells is what you need to
do but who the [__] doesn't want to
watch the Republican lose air day all
day well we're gonna watch him lose
again and again and again as soon as we
come back so don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's it's a rhetorical question
at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim gems skull
near run out Natty light hope it don't
rain tomorrow so we can Circle the city
again here's Bob dear Bob I'm fixing to
send you some more of them Doritos you
like the red bag not the Li l and blue
one in your absence I discovered a rash
on my neck and no it ain't no hickey and
I even seen my cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day here's
tamy [__] them [__] them [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast welcome back to the [__] show as
we watch the clown car
empty and no one's getting out for
speaker in the house of represent is the
Republican con has 16 defectors 16 [__]
you so far to Jim Jordan and you know
what the the more the the thing I want
to tell you too about these 16 fucku
here's the 16 fucku to Jim Jordan [__]
you Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
these aren't just [__] youed to Jim
Jordan they are also [__] youed to
Donald Trump um it's a clear sign that
that there are Republicans in the house
of repres Representatives that know that
they cannot chain their leg to Donald
Trump that it is it is it is imperative
for their seat and them to remain in
Congress that they have to vote
against Donald Trump's
nominee now there's also members in the
house caucus the Republican house caucus
and the Maga
side the the cult members as as we know
them here the cult members they're the
ones
who in all reality are causing this as
well because they must they must
genuflect to the mango musolini Jesus
they must put their Cheeto dust knee
pads on it's the only way that they will
win in their
districts and the challenge is is that
the Republican party is Extreme
everywhere like in blue states where
these Republicans are winning in these
Jerry mener districts don't get it
twisted they'll put a they'll put a MAA
candidate against against one of these
defectors to beat them in the primary
but it's only it's only to reassure that
the Democrats going to win in these
Biden districts you see that right okay
so there's 18 districts that Joe Biden
won that has Republican representatives
in them you follow me now here's the
problem here's the problem if those
Republicans have a primary Challenge
from the right and that primary
challenge wins then they have a Trumper
an
extremist a [__] Marjorie Taylor
green and a Lauren bobbert running in
that District the Democrat it doesn't
matter if if that democrat's a ham
[__] sandwich they're GNA
win which means are you following me
here are you are you with me which means
that the Democrats win the House of
Representatives which means that Hakeem
jeffre is the speaker of the
house it's not [__] complicated stuff
like this is easy [__] why do why do you
think I keep telling you that they're
going to nominate Donald Trump and
that's what we want them to do I know
that feels like well Tony that that's
kind of [__] up you want Donald Trump
to you goddamn right I want Donald Trump
to be their
nominee I want us to stomp his ass again
just like I'm excited that Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan is gonna lose
again on the house floor
today because they [__]
losers and they'll continue to be losers
and as long as they lose it's not only
bad for them it's bad for the country
and if the country finally [__] gets
enough brain cells and wakes their ass
up and realizes that maybe they'll maybe
just maybe just maybe they'll think
about voting for a party that is
destroying our [__] institutions of
democracy here maybe put people in
charge that are serious enough to
[__] do the work that we send we we
are the government it's a democratic
constitutional
republic we elect them to go represent
us they are not representing anyone
right now they can't even get a [__]
leader and Democrats will have a leader
first
ballot first [__] ballot come January
2025 that first week in January 2025
Hakeem jeffre will be over
overwhelmingly elected to be the Speaker
of the
House it'll be done in three
hours by the time they open the floor
they call a
quorum they call the vote for speaker
because that's the first thing that has
to happen you can't do anything without
a speaker I don't know if anyone knows
that that's why they're not going to
have any votes the only votes that
Republicans are going to have until they
have a speaker is two votes well three
votes
quorum vote for speaker Jim Jordan loses
and a vote to go to recess that's all
they can do that's it that's it they're
up to 18 oh man Tony what did Tony heyy
can you let me know what Tony said about
uh what the votes would be today was it
18 to 22 is that what he said y that's
what he
said huh
funny it's almost like this is just a
[__] show in and of itself
and you're thinking why the [__] would
they do this like think about
this if if we have and I'm I promise I'm
gonna get back to the RFK thing I
promise I'm gonna get there but I just
can't [__] do anything but point out
the [__] just the godamn dumpster
fire in the
house this should piss off every single
[__] American I don't give a [__]
what party you're in what ideology you
are this should [__] piss people
off there's only one person responsible
for this only one it's not Kevin
McCarthy it's it's not Joe Biden it's
not Jim Jordan even there's only one
person responsible for all this [__]
chaos and the reason why our government
can't
function Donald
Trump if they if they would have just
impeached that [__] the first
time or impeached him the second time
Mitch McConnell you [__] scumbag you
[__] glitchy ass scumbag
you now what do you think you dumb
[__] do you think what you
should have done is [__] impeached
him and 14th him that's right they could
have 14d him then you know that all that
14th talk with secretaries of state
that's all [__] but the 14th they
could have 14th by impeaching him oh
[__] yeah they could have done that they
could have voted on that [__] and boom
it had been done done done would have
been but MIT Connell stood in the way
because MIT Connell didn't want a former
president who who tried to overturn the
government in their party he didn't want
the
look that the guy they back tried to
overthrow the government and he got 14th
that's what they didn't
want because they're [__] cowards
they didn't do the right thing and here
we are because these Republicans won't
do the right thing we're in we're in
this situation the same thing with Kevin
mcarthy he won't do the right thing he
wouldn't do the right thing he wouldn't
do the right thing increase the debt
ceiling get keep the government open
just bare minimum [__] that you have to
do when you're elected to govern and
here we are they got rid of him because
he did the bare minimum thing which was
govern which was just keep the
government open for
days that's the reason why they can't
pick a speaker is because Kevin McCarthy
got Democrats to help him keep the
government open for 45 days not to
mention what actually happens when the
government stays open which is to make
sure that if you care about anything
else Patriot Patriots you [__] idiots
that fly your American flags because you
think it represents Trump you pieces of
trash which that flag does not represent
Trump but I know that's what you think
it
does [__]
fots it at a bare minimum it pays our
service members at a bare minimum I mean
yeah the federal parts and the borders
less
secure you know you know civil servants
aren't going to get paid certain types
of civil service operations aren't going
to take place America's going to be
affected the economy could be affected
but at a bare minimum you should listen
to your [__] stupid ass lies and your
stupid ass rhetoric about veterans and
the military and oh we really love
military we love veterans support your
veterans you know that stupid sign you
got in the front yard that you would
just otherwise piss on other than to act
like like Tom Cole says Jim Jordan acts
like Jim Jordan acts like he supports
veterans Jim Jordan acts like he
supports people in the military Jim
Jordan acts like he supports he supports
active duty service members he
doesn't he just is
acting because it's all an act with
these [__]
clowns and that's the
point that's the point it's a feature of
the Republican party now because they
Embrace Trump and Trump is at the head
of all this it is an authoritarian
dictatorship inside the Republican party
period he controls them Lock Stock
Barrel you don't need any other excuse
you don't need any other reason why this
is happening all these [__]
know it too every last single one of
these some
[__] in the Republican side know it's
the truth and the reason reason why
again I tell you they didn't want cell
phones in those private conferences
where they were trying to pick a speaker
not because they didn't want [__]
recorded it's because they didn't want
Donald Trump in the room because if they
knew Donald Trump was in the room he
would [__] want someone like Jim
Jordan to be the speaker and that person
would never be able to win on a house
vote floor uh house floor vote to be
speaker of the house they knew it
they knew it they knew they had to trick
Republicans they knew they had to trick
America they had to trick the reporters
and they had to trick Trump into getting
Steve scalish you remember that [__]
remember I said like five minutes before
it was announced that Steve scal was
gonna be the [__] speaker remember
this I said Jim Jordan's gonna be the
Speaker of the House Jim Jordan's gonna
be the speaker of the house I said that
and then Steve scales was going to be
the speaker of the house and I said
maybe he still got to get get the
votes he didn't even take the vote to
the floor and the reason why he didn't
take the vote for the floor is because
they didn't want to go to the floor if
they didn't have
217 and now here we are on day two and
Jim Jordan ain't even [__] close to
sue 217 he's not even at [__] 200
folks come
on come on man
man Hakeem
Jeff is going to win another popular
vote today again because Republicans are
[__] idiots and their constituents
are even dumber than dog [__] than they
are it's the truth it's the truth the
people voting for the Republicans are
[__] brainwashed they're [__]
brainwashed and this is going to keep
happening in this country if we don't
let these [__] brainwash idiots just
touch the hot stove turn that [__]
burner up to high get it boiling and
[__] let them put their hands on it
[__] them put let them put their face on
it it's enough of this [__] it's enough
of Democrats protecting Republicans it's
enough of us trying to make sure that
government functions that our country
functions in a certain [__] way so
that they can keep continuing on with
their goddamn delusions that somehow
Donald Trump is sitting here by God and
he's gonna fix this country whatever the
[__] that
means it's enough of that trash it's
enough of it let them fail [__]
it sometimes you just got to give your
kids tough love and let them [__]
fail and that's what we have to do here
and I know that doesn't feel good and it
doesn't sound good to just let them
[__] fail but it's just going to have
to happen and yes the rest of the
country is probably going to suffer as
because because of
it but there's nothing else to do here
look at this 20 [__]
votes 20 votes to tell Jim Jordan to
[__] off [__] off
you [__] off Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan 20 votes Kevin McCarthy
only had eight
defectors against his speakership only
eight why in the [__] aren't they
someone nominating Kevin McCarthy to see
what they can do oh that's right because
Donald Trump says
no do you get it do you get it every
[__] Republican representative in
this room knows that Kevin McCarthy can
get more votes than Jim Jordan he can
get closer to 27
217 and they still do
nothing they still do
nothing and the reason why they do
nothing and they're still going to
nominate Jim Jordan tomorrow and the
next day and it's going to be stupid and
the next day and the next day it's going
to be stupid oh my God eventually I'm
going to just [__] take screenshots
and show you how he lost because it's
gonna be so [__] redundant like we're
not we're gonna get tired of them
losing literally we're gonna get sick
and tired of Jim Jordan losing I know
that sounds like it's not possible but
trust me three four days of this [__]
and it will get [__] exhausting to
watch him lose again and again and again
and again and again and again I'm gonna
have to move on and talk about something
else than this [__] loser and their
loser party and their loser caucus and
their loser
leader because the reason why they're
losing is because they are an
authoritarian party they are a
dictatorship and the Cheeto
dust MAA King is at the head of it so
[__] him let him lose there it is 21 now
let's move back to the RFK thing because
oh man I'm really excited to talk to you
about this so let's talk about the RFK
thing because the rightwing is freaking
the [__] out and the one thing they
can't do they can't get their messaging
out about RFK because all this Jim
Jordan [__] like and top that off
they've either gota they've either gotta
be on hamas's side or they gotta be on
is Israel's side they can't decide that
either the right wing can't [__]
figure that [__] out neither can the
left wing if you want to be completely
honest because like I told you yesterday
people just get [__] brain farts when
it comes to ideology but you know we'll
get there I promise we'll get there
don't don't don't don't let what you see
out in the public discourage you because
if you get discouraged someone else get
discouraged just be ready to [__]
vote vote vote vote get to the ballot go
to the go to the battleground of the
ballot and do your job that a democracy
is designed to do an engage in it have
strategic outrage and point that
strategic outrage towards the ballot
that's the best weapon we have to save
our democracy folks if you want to know
the God's honest
truth here's here the RFK Jr everyone's
totally distracted right totally [__]
distracted but what they did was is they
convinced they convinced a core part of
their base that RFK Jr was really cool
he's got muscles oh man what what
pleases some [__] fragile white man
than some dude who has muscles like
they'll jerk off to [__] RFK Jr with
his shirt off way way way sooner than
they
will sexy pictures of Taylor Swift now
think about that think think of the
world that we're living in right now
these [__] these [__] fragile
white men these hopped up men on Sports
uh uh nonay beer and porn right these
[__] they can't they much would much
rather jerk off the pictures and videos
of RFK with his shirt
off than than sexy pictures of Taylor
Swift I'm I'm serious that's where we're
at here that's where we're at that's how
they [__] diluted these minds of
these idiots right these right-wing
Insel fragile white men but they
convinced the core part of the base that
not only is RFK buff oh man oh man he
make good prison he's got
muscles that [__] matters the last
dude that you had president you think
he's a God he doesn't have a [__]
muscle on his body I mean he does he
does have a a hamburger muscle down in
his tummy his tummy tum oh man that
[__] muscle gets worked out every
day but they thought RFK had muscles and
then and then they heard that this guy
[__] hates vaccines not only does
hate vaccines he blames it on China and
all kinds of crazy ass 10 full hat
conspiracy theory [__] and they're like
yeah we not only does this guy have
muscles he's a [__] idiot oh my God
he's a [__] idiot and boy do the
idiots love idiots they're like yeah he
makes us feel
smart that's so cool RFK Junior says
some dumb [__] and it really it sounds
really smart and it makes me sound
really smart when I go talk to my when I
go talk to my cousin naate Dean oh naate
she just she can't she can't even
[__] she can't even have a comeback
when I tell her the RFK stuff that he
tells me oh my God it's so cool that's
the people we're talking
about um Kim
says it's 22 now
yeah it's almost like what did I say ear
there hey could can someone can someone
grab me what I said what the what the
count was gonna be against Jim Jordan
the [__] you's how many was it what was
it what was
it it's not that difficult to understand
folks
here it is I'll show it to you ah boom
okay let's get back to the RFK the the
right-wing insults jerking off to RFK
right so they [__] love idiots
especially idiots that have muscles oh
my God that is a thing that they love
and what happened was is the right-wing
the the the Deep Web the banon part of
the party convinced these idiots that
RFK was so cool I mean they were posting
about it they were posting like
videos of him bench pressing you know 90
pounds like three times and they're like
look this guy's on steroids he's on gear
he's got muscles and he's so cool that's
I mean literally right-wingers were
saying i' I my President should have
muscles and [__] like that right so they
basically convinced their entire base
that RFK was cool as [__] oh man he's a
badass and then RFK believed that [__]
right so the idiot believe that he's not
really an idiot he's really smart all
the army of idiots convinced him that he
should run well can't run in the
Democratic party because that's not how
it [__] works I don't know if I said
that a thousand times that you there's
not going to be a primary Challenger
against Joe Biden because he wants to
run and he's the incumbent and he at 81
million
votes and he has no defection in his
party for the super delegates I don't
know if you guys know how superdelegates
work or not if you're if you used to be
a Bernie bro or you follow when Bernie
Sanders got his ass kicked by Hillary
Clinton then maybe you understand super
delegates but if you understand super
delegates you understand that no
Democratic sitting incumbent president
is going to have a challenger if there's
no defection amongst the superdelegates
which there is
not that means he's the nominee I don't
know if you know that but that's how it
works inside the Democratic party you
may not like it you may not like that
truth you may not like that truth but
that's the truth uh looks like we're
we're winding down to the end here uh
let me let me show you the vote I'm
going to get back to this RFK St I
promise Jim Jordan doesn't even have
200 oh my God he do even have 200 it's
like Tony said he wasn't even gonna
hardly get the 200 son of a [__] some
[__] so Jim Jordan is at 198 hem jeffre
is winning the popular vote at 2113 now
you just watch the column go over to
213 for Hakeem Jeff now looks like the
Voting is in it looks like that is the
tally so it's going to be
198 213 and 22 fucku to Jim Jordan there
it is if if Patrick McHenry starts to
speak I'll I'll bring him up because uh
he's the Kirk has the clerk has to close
the vote now once they close the vote
they have to record the vote once the
vote is recorded then they will announce
the vote and then we'll see if Patrick
McKenry either calls for another vote
for speaker or if he moves to a recess
we'll see what happens because that's
all Patrick McKenry can do he can either
call another Vote or he can or he can
just go to a recess that's his choices
he doesn't have much Choice he can't
move in any other business without
having the Fool's power of the
speakership oh boy oh boy boy it be it'd
be a good idea to know the truth and the
rules speaking of the truth and the
rules uh is that maanga the reason why
they're freaking out about RFK is the
truth is that they convinced their
entire incel base that RFK had muscles
he was cool he's an idiot and they love
idiots and now he's running as an
independent because they they convince
RFK of the same thing that if you know
the truth about the Democratic primary
RFK was never going to challenge Joe
Biden Democratic primary there's no way
it wasn't going to happen it no one was
even Gavin Nome could not challenge Joe
Biden he could not I I know I know some
people want to say that stupid [__] like
on tyt marann wison and
janker it's [__] dumb as
[__] if you believe that stuff then you
need you need to wake a little up a
little bit too because that's all
[__] and ain't how it works so RFK
was never going to be a democratic
nominee and the Republicans do that and
they kept stoking this fire that he was
so cool and then he's like you know what
I'll just be an into dependent I'll just
leave the Democratic party I believe my
own [__] I believe the right-wing's
[__] I believe all these people in
my social media comments they [__]
love me they love my muscles and they
love that I'm an idiot so I'm gonna run
as on the idiot candidate on idiot
ticket so he goes and runs on the idiot
ticket right as an independent and the
more polling that comes out shows that
RFK Jr is [__] taking votes away from
Trump that's what the polls are showing
again don't believe polls they're all
[__] right they might be real they
might be true but that you shouldn't
believe them you shouldn't believe
them that's that's the craziest thing is
that the right-wing does believe polls
because the polls are all [__] and
they're [__] lies it feeds their lies
right that's what it does is it feeds
that [__] delusion and that
brainwashing and that absolute [__]
just sludge of our political body and
right now they're freaking out because
RFK Jr is taking votes away from Donald
Trump in those
polls and they don't know what to do
because they convince these brainless
idiots that RFK junor is really [__]
cool he's really [__] cool and you
should go vote for him right and it's
gonna seep out it's gonna get past it's
G to get past the [__] online incels
it's going to start to leak out and
they're terrified that it's going to
leak out so they really got to step back
their narrative that RFK isn't cool he's
not cool well that's the problem with
these with these
[__] incels these internet [__]
trolls is once the cat's out of the bag
you can't put the cat back in the bag
that's what Trump's about that's the
that's what we're going through with
[__] Donald Trump is they convince
all these idiots that hey Donald Trump
will let you be the worst version of
yourself and you don't even have to fret
because the worst case scenario you just
leave all your other social media
platforms and go over to that dumpster
fire Twitter and they'll let you say and
be and do anything you want online oh my
God you can say the most racist vile
[__] and you can be against anyone you
want you don't have to have any
compassion you don't have to have any
love for the institution of democracy
matter of fact you can claim that you
love America even at the same time
hating that's [__] guts and not even
knowing the history you can make up your
own [__] history if you want to know
the honest truth on on Twitter you can
do that and they convince them of this
and that's why you see trumpers over
there Jesus Christ I get these [__]
idiots in the YouTube comments oh my God
let me show you I wore this hat I think
it was last week I wear this hat last
week this is this is a this is a [__]
Halloween hat okay this is a hat from
Save By the Bell right they [__] hate
this hat on YouTube the right Wingers so
I did some YouTube videos
and there was like four five six seven
comments in each video that we posted
with this hat in it nice hat bro oh nice
stay by the Bell hat where'd you get
that your momy get that at the [__]
Halloween store for you no I went and
bought it but I like the Hat it's a
funny hat and actually for you know to
tell you hon the truth I'm gonna wear
this [__] hat more because it pisses
you
off I'm talking to Manga Here I I'm
gonna wear this hat more you [__] eaters
because it pisses you off you people are
so [__] weak you're so predictable
You're such blo hards it's no wonder the
right-wing was able to convince you
Trump is cool that Trump is smart it's
no wonder the [__] the [__]
right-wing taught you was able to
convince you and dup you that RFK Jr is
smart that he's not some [__] T full
hat conspiracy theorist idiot that he's
oh he got muscles he got he got muscles
he got
muscles
so your best comment that you got in my
[__] video about how you're a bunch
of [__] fascist is well well we might
be fascist and we might be Nazis but at
least we don't wear a dumb say by the
Bell hat okay good one good one keep up
keep it up in the comments you [__]
losers go for it I I I'm telling you man
I I might go buy more of these hats
frankly if you want me to buy more of
these hats right now go right now now
either go to the Tony
michaels.com buy me a shot you can leave
me a message there or go to the ven uh
the venmo Super Chat link go to the Tony
michaels.com leave me some money I I'll
buy more of these [__] hats and I
will wear more of hats just like this
that look stupid as [__] I will wear
them on air I will [__] wear them on
air just to piss these [__] idiots
off go do it right now I I'll I'll pay
attention hell I'll bring your your
message up on screen since it's a venos
Super Chat just go to Theon michaels.com
put a Vinos Super Chat tell me it's for
the hat and I'll do it I'll buy more of
them we'll go on Amazon together [__]
we'll pick them out together we'll pick
them out together live here on air let's
do this because I I am about getting in
their Grill any way we can and if RFK Jr
is the thing that rake they step on [__]
it let's call them let's [__] point
it out how ridiculous they are because
here's what's happening when the right
wing is pointing out that Donald Trump
is going to lose votes because of RFK Jr
they're telling the right-wing that
they're telling the people that they
tried to convince that RFK Junior was
really cool now they're trying to
convince him that he's not so cool
anymore they can't take that cat out of
the bag and not only are they not going
to do that now all the [__]
right-wing incels online are going to be
fighting each other they're gonna be
fighting each other the delusional
fighting the delusional it's like a
[__] rabid sheep fight you know what
I mean oh God rat rat can we get can we
get uh Rat can we get um can we get some
sort of [__] image of sheep rabidly
fighting sheep um rat and if you make a
note of that some people are G to be
like is he talking to a rat yes I'm
talking to a rat we're GNA talk more
about that too we're gonna have more of
that to come but we that's what we need
we need we need rabid sheep fighting
Ravid sheep over RFK Jr
that's we need to put that out there
speaking of put that out there here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to go to
a quick break when we come back uh we'll
go to the the the house floor again I'm
going to show you the final vote and
then hopefully we'll hear from the Elf
on the Shelf the acting the protm
speaker to see if they're going to call
recess or not which they will don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny we know what you would do you'd
reach out and give that true American a
hand now here's your chance for only $50
a day you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those Trump
supporters and this is that moment send
your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast welcome back to the
show Jim I don't report sex Grimes
Jordan has been Jim I'm a two-time loser
for the speakership Jordan
today boo [__] who
are you sad that they're losing are you
I'm not sad that they're losing uh I but
I'm telling you we may get a little sick
and tired of this [__] here it is here's
the Here's the final vote they're
waiting for the final roll call here
it's 199 212 Hakeem Jeff wins the
popular vote again there's 22 [__]
you to Jim
Jordan because that's truly what they
are they're not votes for people they're
votes against Jim Jordan Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan and that's the
reason why there's 22 votes against Jim
I just lost for the second time because
I'm a big [__] loser
Jordan that's the reason
why speaker Hakeem Jeffrey sounds pretty
good doesn't it doesn't that sound good
guess what you can make that happen
that's right you you out there you The
Listener can make that happen you can
engage in your democracy and make sure
that this country knows how [__]
inept the clown car caucus is the
Republicans the MAA Republicans in this
country the Trump puppets that they are
and that's the reason why it's happening
is because Trump is their Puppet Master
he is controlling
them that's why Kevin McCarthy is not
the speaker I mean Jesus Christ look at
this Kevin McCarthy has a better vote
that the the speaker they just had that
they got of has a better vote
count than Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan and that's pretty [__]
pathetic that's pretty [__] pathetic
that someone can get a worse vote count
than Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy is a
[__]
[__] Kevin MCM [__] is what his name
should be maybe it'll be that
henceforth and he soon won't even be a
member of Congress the only reason why
he's staying Congress is just in case he
needs to be speaker again wouldn't that
be [__]
hilarious they can't get the goddamn
government open because they can't elect
the speaker and then then they have to
revert back to Kevin McCarthy to get the
government back open so they're not
blamed for the [__] that they need to be
blamed for because it is their fault
they can't put a caucus together to do
the the business of the
people Democrats are elected next year
and they can do the thing that they did
today Democrats do with the thing they
did today and vote for a real Speaker of
the House someone who's actually going
to do the work a real true leader Hakeem
Jeff pluck your heads out of your
[__] ass MAA and understand if you
want an operational
government you should vote Democrat but
that's the point isn't it that's the
point they don't want a government they
don't want a functional government they
do not want a democracy they they don't
want a God damn they do not want a House
of Representatives that is going to be
passing bills to make sure that people
have their rights they do not want the
House of Representatives to codify the
right to women to have health care they
definitely don't want
that they definitely do not want do not
want a House of Representatives that
does the work of the people because
that's woke oh my God democracy is woke
and it's a bad thing oh my that that
goddamn democracy
it's [__] woke we have a republic we
don't need to have that woke democracy
stuff that extends people to other than
whites you know what I mean whites are
the only ones that should have rights
that's why we don't want a government
governing things godamn and if you get
serious empathetic people that are doing
the work of the people in the House of
Representatives we have all kinds of
woke [__] going on in this country like
infrastructure fixing your [__]
highways in your Bridges bringing
Broadband to the country the rural areas
out to these Hillbillies and rednecks oh
my God can you even imagine bringing
bringing jobs here to America from
China about chips
microchips oh my God that would be
horrible if if those woke Democrats did
that kind of stuff make sure that
veterans got their health care that they
sold earned and deserve oh my God you
talk about some woke [__] uh oh we've
got a um looks like we got a graphic of
two sheep going at
it ask and you shall
receive ask and you shall receive let's
see if I can get this
one let's see let's
see maybe maybe it's on
here load that thing as in in as an
overlay that's what you should do rat
rat throw that thing in as an overlay
that you just put on Discord and we're
gonna we're going to show you the Sheep
fighting here the Ravid sheep fighting
uh here I give you another floor here's
a special view ah man it it it turns the
view it changed the view
here is there any other news besides
Republicans or [__] losers oh yes oh
yes um there was a
rocket that hit a Hospital in Gaza City
apparently uh everyone on the Internet
is a citizen
journalist and they all stepped in it
because they all said it was Israel and
it was not Israel the data has shown the
American government has analyzed the
data apparently and there's no way that
that rocket could have come from Israel
it's not Israelis that set that Rec that
rocket off that it must be a Palestinian
ter a small cell of Palestinian
terrorist and that rocket off now this
is this thunder is being felt all around
the Arab world um as as in that region
of our
Earth near Israel and near Gaza uh is is
erupting into high
tensions uh with that rocket being shot
into a hospital
now and you know again I I'm going to
keep my stance on this that humanity is
where need to be
folks humanity is where we have to be we
cannot get outside that outside Humanity
it is super important that we do
not humanity is the most important
thing being
Humane and to take take a moment to take
a breath to figure out where the rocket
came from and why the rocket hit the
hospital it's part of that
Humanity nope can't do that the
[__] Twitter and the left and the
left there's two United States Congress
women who blame this on America and
Israel without knowing the facts these
are people who are supposed to be
serious without having the facts I guess
even Keith OB was blaming the Israelis
for the rocket he had to go apologize
well Keith dude just get with the truth
first especially when it's like a rocket
going into a
hospital
okay and when you get down to the truth
and the facts like I told you yesterday
that all there's a lot of truth that can
be true all at the same time
and it may be confusing when you send it
through the political
filter because we don't understand
ideology and that's a big problem like
Benjamin netanyahu's ideology I am not
in agreeance with his ideology there are
going to be very [__] few things that
I
stand and say that I I agree with
Benjamin Netanyahu on his [__]
ideology frankly I wish that
[__] would have never been the
prime minister of Israel a lot of
Israelis I'm I'm I'm here to tell you I
believe that this conflict is going to
make it clear that Benjamin Netanyahu
should not be the prime minister of
Israel and maybe they'll get someone
that's more reasonable that doesn't want
to oppress the rights of people or take
away democracy for the people of [__]
Israel that's a truth that I can tell
you right here right now that's a truth
but it's also the truth that Hamas are a
bunch of [__] fascist terrorists and
they went went slaughtered and committed
war crimes in
Israel and and yesterday oh excuse me I
got to go back to the floor here um
we'll get back to this talk here Let The
Honorable Jim Jordan of the state of
Ohio has received
199 The Honorable hakee Jeff of the
state of New York has received
212 winner MIM Jeff the
winner
The Honorable Kevin McCarthy of the
State of California has received five
The Honorable Byron Donalds of the State
of Florida has received one The
Honorable Tom emmer of the state of
Minnesota has received
one Lee zeldon of the state of New York
has received three three Steve of the
state of Louisiana received seven oh my
God The Honorable Mike Garcia of the
State of California has received one
Candace Miller of the state of Michigan
is received
one John Boehner of the state of Ohio
has received
[Applause]
one are you [__] [__] me no way
the honorable K Granger of the State of
Texas has received one The Honorable
Bruce Westerman of the state of Arkansas
has received one no person having
received a majority the whole number of
votes cast by surname a
has not been
elected pursuant to Clause 12a of rule
one the chair declares the house and
recess subject to the call of the chair
oh call the
chair oh boy so there they go They're
going to Reon that's the end result of
there you go oh boy they're not going to
take another vote who' guest
it it's almost like someone told you
that was gonna happen it's almost like
someone told you it was going to happen
now I'm going to get back to the the
rocket in the hospital thing I'll get
back to to it I
promise John Boehner okay do you I don't
know if you guys know who the [__] John
Boehner is John Boehner was the Speaker
of the House John Boehner was forced out
by the freedom
caucus and Mark Meadows you mark men the
Tea Party caucus the freedom caucus you
those [__] idiots the
maglites yeah prea MGA okay this is
before Donald Trump
existed inside their Universe right
before he was their cult
leader
so so John Boehner was the speaker of
the house and was forced out when he was
forced to retire John Boehner said I'm
not only not GNA be speaker I'm not GNA
be a congressman because that's how it
works like n gingers when he's forced
out he couldn't be a congressman anymore
when you don't win as the Speaker of the
House you don't be a congressman anymore
if you're a republican it's how it works
if you're a republican if you're a
Democrat there's no disgrace in it
because you actually passed the gavel to
the new leadership like Nancy Pelosi
passed the leadership gavel to Hakeem
Jeff everything was successful she
passed it on to
him Republicans are not that way
Republicans are not successful they're
not winners they're
losers and John Boehner was a [__]
loser and when John Boehner decided now
I don't know if you remember this when
John Boehner decided he was going to
retire he wasn't going to be the speaker
anymore he definitely wasn't going to a
congressman anymore his second in charge
was Kevin McCarthy do you know who Kevin
McCarthy is are you guys aware of who
that guy is that's the guy who just got
vacated yes he's the guy that just got
vacated
so and I gotta pull this graphic up rat
got rat got the graphic he got it in
here's here's the Sheep fighting the
Sheep
furiously it's the Sheep
contest ask and you shall receive from
the lab
rant um I got a mad scientist working
behind the scenes here our show mascot
the rat so here's the thing so when John
Boehner decided to retire Kevin McCarthy
couldn't be speaker because he's an
idiot and he went on Fox News and he
said these words the reason why Hillary
Clinton is losing is because of the
Benghazi
committee the Benghazi special committee
has
been helped to lower the polls that was
the intention everyone knew that
everyone knew it was the the Republicans
weaponizing government against Hillary
Clinton's
campaign right it was the idea that they
were just going to make [__] up have her
get in front of a committee for 11 hours
she's not scared of taking questions
from Trey gouty for 11
hours and
that they would hurt her campaign well
Kevin McCarthy couldn't be speaker
because of those facts so what happened
was is they had to beg someone to be a
speaker I mean beg them oh my God they
had to beg and beg and beg Paul Ryan you
remember this
right Paul Ryan did not want to be the
speaker of the house and the reason why
Paul Ryan did not want to be the speaker
of the house because he knows the rules
if you become the Republican speaker of
the house you will not be a congressman
anymore
eventually guess what happened to Paul
Ryan not only did he did he quit running
for congress as he wasn't the
speaker and now today today they went
all the way back because you don't have
to be a member of the House to be the
speaker I don't know if anyone knows
that you remember from the Kevin
McCarthy vote Matt gats nominated Donald
Trump and he got votes you remember that
Donald Trump got votes back in
January because you don't have to to be
a member of the house to get speaker
votes you don't have to be a member of
the House to be speaker there's no rule
saying
that
so John Boehner gets a vote are you
[__] kidding me what a bunch of
[__] jokes what a bunch of
jokes Jokers everywhere in the speaker
of the house and here it is here's
here's the moment again uh where where
oh now hang on let me get my screen
right I got I got to get it I got to get
it right here now here's the moment
where the Elf on the Shelf Patrick
McKenry is that what we're calling him
still Elf on the Shelf I don't know
maybe I'm maybe I'm being an [__] but
the El and the shelle Patrick McHenry
here calling the vote for for John
Boehner of the state of Michigan has
received
one John Boehner of the state of Ohio
has received
one they think that's cute don't
they what a bunch of [__] what a
bunch of Jack offs huh these [__]
Jack offs are you kidding me they're
cheering that so let's get back to this
this rocket thing and then we'll go back
to the house I promise I want to finish
my commentary on the rocket it's much
more serious than clowning the
clowns but some must be clowned even in
the serious story of the rocket so there
were several people that
um came out and before they knew the
facts because the facts are important
especially when we're talking about
these things that are happening over in
the Middle
East
and Keith Oberman was one of them
apparently it came out on Twitter and I
can look it up if you want but do I
really have to um but there was two
congresswomen who decided to speak
before the facts are out
and they made fools of
themselves and this is what I was trying
to say yesterday is you must make
Humanity first doesn't matter the
ideology Humanity should be
first and then you work through your
ideology once you've got the humanity
down
pth and they forgot that point they
forgot that you must consider Humanity
first and get the facts straight so that
that when you make your ideology known
that you don't look like a [__]
idiot because two representatives in
Keith obman and many others many others
those aren't the only ones but many
others out there saying what they said
before they knew the [__] facts and
got the facts straight and getting into
their ideology before the facts
especially about this conflict in
Gaza and in
Israel you make us believe that you're
not serious about your commentary and
that the [__] you're saying you don't
actually
believe that's the problem that a lot of
commentators have that's why I'm hard on
anyone I don't give a [__] who they are
left or right if you're inauthentic in
your commentary then sit down and shut
the [__] up quit being in in insincere
quit being
unauthentic stop feeding your audience a
bunch of bull
[__] tell them what you think and how
you feel through your filter of ideology
be honest with them be transparent with
them I'm transparent with you here I
don't hold anything back I don't tell
you anything any I'm not I I don't
benefit in my commentary to tell you a
bunch of [__]
lies just because it makes me look good
or it makes you like me there's a lot of
people in the comments over the last
several the last couple weeks that have
hated what the [__] I have said about
Gaza about Palestinians about the the
Israeli conflict and the terrorist
attack that happened in Israel and
Israel having the right to go and go
defend themselves and get the terrorists
that committed those those war
crimes they don't like that [__] there's
people in the chat right now that
probably don't like me saying that that
don't stand with me on
that
and that's okay that's okay to
disagree but don't feed people with a
bunch of
[__] don't lie to
people don't [__] don't be saying
[__] just to say it because people want
to like you or you want a certain group
of people to like
you get the [__] out of here with that
[__] either stand on your principles
or
don't and if you can't handle doing
commentary standing on your principles
and what you believe is true based on
your
ideology then don't that's the problem
that I have with the rightwing most of
the time the right-wing
commentators that's what I have a
problem with them most of the time
and here's the problem I am with them is
they're they're feeding their audiences
for a bunch of lies and [__] that
they don't actually believe they don't
believe any that [__] you think Sean
Hannity has any kind of principles
left do you think Tucker Carlson had any
kind of principles left are you kidding
me he knew the [__] he was saying was
[__] lies
and even when he knew it was lies he was
telling his audience lies and he knew he
was [__] misinforming them
intentionally misinforming
them if I tell you something that's not
true on the show it's not because I'm
intentionally doing it you know I'll say
I'm wrong when I'm
wrong because I believe it's so
important but when you jump the gun on
something like a rocket being fired in a
hospital in Gaza City when you know the
conflict that going is going on and you
know the facts leading up to that
event in the past two
weeks you would know to either hold your
commentary or just tell the [__]
facts don't make
assumptions and Stoke of fire that's
already there we're talking about
[__] War here we're not we're not
we're not talking about politics
folks there are [__] children in Gaza
City that are going to get killed
because Hamas decided to go commit war
crimes and atrocities in Israel and
Israel is going to defend itself and
Hamas has been known known to stand in
front of women and children and hide
behind women children hide in
hospitals they've been known to do
that there are going to be innocent
people killed in it it always happens
this way in
war but the difference that you want to
know the difference between what Hamas
when they killed innocent people it was
unprovoked oh but Tony Israel's been
doing this for years blah blah blah blah
blah blah it's war crimes to kill
civilians
unprovoked we're not talking about
collateral
damage when you're when you're
attacking an institution a group of
people who has committed acts of
War know the [__]
rules know the [__] rules there's
actually international law I don't know
I don't know if you [__] chuckleheads
know this there's International raw
international law dictating what is war
crimes and what is not and what is acts
of War and what is civilians being
slaughtered and an act of
Terror and what it means to have
collateral damage
and
frankly if you don't got your [__]
head on straight you shouldn't be
talking about the
[__] and a lot of these people go back
and they talk about [__] the history
of that part of the
world and they conflate the history of
Israel and Hamas and they conflate the
history of Palestine and the Arab world
in
general to each and every single
event and when you conflate the history
with the actual event that's happening
you're doing the same thing maanga does
with the black lives matter protest
comparing it to the January 6
Insurrection you [__]
idiots and yeah I'm not just talking a
manga here there's a lot on the left
that are doing this [__] and conflating
this [__] and you may not like me saying
it the way I'm saying it it may get you
all really upset that oh Tony's Tony's
being paid to say something because I
got that [__] in the comments too I'm
paid to say [__]
[__] I wish I was [__] paid
to say [__] I would be saying a whole
other do you know how right-wing I would
be if I was being paid to say [__] you
know how easy it is to lie to
right-wingers you know how easy it is to
attract a [__] a [__] audience of
white male
incels fragile males in this country oh
it's [__] easy especially when you
look and sound like
me so if you think I'm being [__]
paid to do something you're you're just
as dumb as MAA and you need to have your
[__] head
checked get your [__] head checked
it's the audience that supports this
show it's the audience and some of the
audience support this show and they
don't even believe what I'm saying right
now in this
moment but they believe in the [__]
truth and they believe when someone is
out there telling them all kinds of hor
[__] that ain't [__] true that
they're not doing any favors to them or
democracy and when you're shoveling
horeshit down people's throats because
you don't know the facts about a missile
that hit a hospital in Gaza City you're
a [__] grifter and you ain't nothing
but a you ain't nothing but a goddamn
liar just because you're conflating
issues and you ain't no goddamn better
than the daily wire or or Steve bannon's
war room or any of the other Fox News o
or Newsmax to be perfectly [__]
honest with
you so get right with the [__] facts
and get right with the truth and if you
want the real raw truth that's why you
come
here the show is not designed to
[__] you the show is not designed to
stroke your stupid little [__] ego or
to make you feel good about
politics frankly sometimes you got to
laugh at them because it's [__]
hilarious as we just watched the the the
[__] clown
car in the House of
Representatives absolutely lose again
couldn't even select a
speaker and the Elf on the
Shelf had to go to
recess okay the acting protm speaker The
Elf on the Shelf had to go to recet
because they can't get a speaker because
they got to
regroup which is dumb as dog [__] thank
you rant for the elf on the shelf by the
way they're dumb as dog [__] so don't be
dumb as dog [__] don't listen to [__]
people that are trying to mislead you to
get clicks and likes and get oh man we
really need them clicks and likes we
need our video to go
viral either one the truth or don't want
the truth and there's all kinds of
things that can be true all at the same
time even though it [__] with your
ideology it can happen that
way we see we see lefties all around the
country holding a pride flag and a
Palestinian flag and that [__] just does
not make
sense does not make sense Hamas is in
control of Palestine the Palestinians
they control the Palestinians do you
understand that the Palestinians are not
free they're controlled by Hamas it is
their governing
body they haven't had an election in
almost 20 goddamn years since they were
elected into
Power understand it and
Hamas anyone anyone who would be holding
a Palestinian flag and a pride flag in
one hand and the other they would
[__] murder them on
sight because they're fascist murdering
terrorist get it through your thick
[__] skull they are not allies they
are not for
Humanity they want to strip Palestinians
of their [__]
humanity and they have stripped
Palestinians of their Humanity it's one
of the issues that they have in
Gaza get it right in your [__]
brain if you want a free
Palestine are you following me if you
want to free Palestine and you want to
free the Palestinians then free
them from Hamas don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
Hardon blanket I've got you covered part
in blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
paron blanket will protect you too
Parton blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show the
Tony Michaels podcast
sorry to take a break there I thought it
was
a oh we lost some Lind viewers they
probably didn't like what I was
saying I didn't like what I was saying
you know what I
say we're here for the truth ready you
like it or not there's some truth that I
don't [__] like I don't like the
[__] truth I don't like that Donald
Trump's controlling the House of
Representatives I do not like that the
truth is that the only one that they can
nominate for speaker that can get that
many votes is Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan you think I like that
truth I mean it's laughable it's kind of
hilarious if you want to know the honest
truth but it's disgusting as well all
those things can be true all at the same
time but it's the truth what do you want
from me it's the [__] truth it's what
you got to get to we got to stop doing
this [__] where we dance
around the truth and the truth is some
of these people are just complete
[__] idiots let me uh let me show you
one of the idiots here oh this is great
I think this is going to be a good
one um this is margorie Taylor green
talking about people calling her a
fascist oh baby this is the kind of
content I'm here for let's listen to
margorie Taylor green whine and cry
about how we're calling her fascist
let's see let's see if we can listen to
her's get it going Marge you want to
know what's dangerous yeah they have
called president Trump Hitler and called
him Nazi they've called me Nazi oh [__]
she's got it did you hear that she's
hearing us she hears me oh my God Marge
is this a love letter to me oh my God is
this a love letter to me because I've
been calling them Nazis long before
anyone else was calling them Nazis long
before anyone else was calling them
Nazis I was calling Donald Trump a Nazi
I was calling Mar trayor green a Nazi
the pety yeti a Nazi I was calling them
Nazis way way way back years ago years
ago [__] out of here with this [__] you
are a [__] Nazi you're all Nazis why
what don't you get I mean if you're
upset about me calling you a Nazi I'm
talking to you they someone drove by
their bicycle today outside the
courtroom and called me a fascist they
call oh my God how dangerous that
freedom of speech that was had on a
bicycle did you hear what she said she
said the most dangerous thing in this
country is someone on a bicycle riding
by her office yelling the word fascist
at her oh my God how dare they how dare
they Ed the freedom of speech [__] out
of here with this nonsense keep going
you dumbass call us names all the time
why isn't their speech being gagged why
isn't their speech oh oh oh why why why
can't they call me a you know what I
want I want them not to have freedom of
speech that's what she's saying here
that's what makes her what's it called
hey what's it called when you when you
don't want people have freedom of speech
and rights what's that oh fascist
[__] stupid ass [__] what the [__]
are you kidding me is this real this
can't be real this cannot be this has to
be [__] AI I don't believe this I
don't believe this for a second this
cannot be real this has to be [__] AI
there is no way this dumb son of a [__]
sat in front of a goddamn cell phone and
said this [__] no one can be this
[__] dumb can they can they really be
this [__] dumb is that a
thing Jesus [__] Christ are you are
you [__] me right now well let's
keep going let's see what the AI machine
says surely this is [__] AI someone
cannot be this stupid being censored why
isn't their speech being weighed in the
public court of opinion do you hear what
she's saying do you hear what the AI
machine saying this is [__] real I I
don't want to believe that it's there's
no way someone's this [__] dumb right
there's no way she's this dumb or am I
wrong come
on listen to what she's saying let me
back it up let me back it up she's
saying what they want listen to what
they listen to what she wants all the
time why isn't their speech being gagged
why isn't their speech being censored
why isn't their speech being weighed in
the public court of opinion and weighed
in courtrooms is being disparaging and
inflammatory and inciting violence
against come at me come at me you
[__] fascist come at me you [__]
Nazi hey hey Nazi trailer green send me
a [__] ceas to assist do it do it try
to gag my speech do it I dare you do
it you [__] feckless fascist you weak
piece of [__] there is no way that
someone is this [__] dumb to tell the
freedom of speeches ah First Amendment
Second Amendment that's the only two
well they know the Fifth Amendment now
they knew the First Amendment freedom of
speech that's all they know about it
they don't know anything else about the
First Amendment besides it it lets me
say whatever I want to say without
consequence that's not what it says
dummy and then the second amendment
they're like yeah guns
PE they know those two amendments and
now they know the Fifth Amendment
because they're [__] mangle melini
Jesus can't [__] say two words
without incriminating himself so he's
got to use his Fifth Amendment all the
time he does not he does he has the
right to remain silent but he has does
not have the [__] ability neither do
this [__] idiot this cannot be real
can we get a verification on this this
cannot be real that she is saying this
[__] out loud listen to her again what
she wants to do to our speech of calling
her a [__] Nazi called me a fascist
you are a fascist call us names all the
time I do all the time I do it all the
time I'm gonna do it right now and I'm
gonna keep doing it I'm GNA keep using
my First Amendment right my freedom of
speech to call you what you are a
[__] feckless fascist you goddamn
Nazi keep going
listen to her why isn't their speech
being gagged why isn't their speech
being censored why isn't their speech
being weighed in the public court of
opinion listen have I ever told you on
this show have you ever heard me utter
the words why is margerie Taylor green
allowed to say that why aren't we
gagging margerie Taylor Green from
saying these dumb things why aren't we
doing that because I don't believe in
that I don't believe in that I've told
you time and time and time again what
what we should do what we should do is
we should make sure to protect the
rights of Nazis like this [__]
scumbag to go down on an overpass in
Florida and show us who they are and to
H Hitler and all their [__] and say
hateful things they can't act on their
hate those are hate crimes that's
different when you act on your hate
speech those are hate
crimes but I want to protect their right
to [__] because if we protect them we
will protect you for sure but they don't
want that they don't want freedom of
speech they want the freedom of their
religion to push on
you that's what they want that's what
makes them what's the word
fascist [__] pieces of trash okay we
got a few um you guys good God I'm going
to be able to buy a couple hats here
I went on about earlier I told you the
hats and I told you guys if you want me
to buy hats you know you can go to venmo
chat well you guys did not disappoint
here uh let me let me let me get these
up on screen
here it's a little it's a little wonky
here to how we got to do it so this is
this is from theren theren says 90
radical 90 hat shopping that's right
we're gonna get some leftwing radical
Kami hats Kami hats from the 90s these
are these are woke Lids okay these are
woke Lids maybe we'll come up with some
kind of name for them um let's see here
Tammy Tammy says let's see let me pull
this one up Tammy says here hang on I
gotta I gotta I gotta do these one at a
time and it's kind of a pain in the ass
because YouTube hates my guts but that's
just how it is Tammy says here you can
get one of those peeee hats with the
spinning tops yeah I'd have to move my
headphones back but I
could
yeah you if we're going to clown them we
might as well clown them proper right
Tammy so thank you Tammy uh we'll get
some hats with that as well let's see
who else do we
[Music]
have Uncle Fatty's got a big one here
let me see if I can fit all this on the
screen I'm not sure if I can put all
this up but we'll try it hell this is
this is live on a why not we'll try it
do it live do it live U Uncle Fanny says
[__] them save by the bill donation he
wants me to get some hats too for the
the all the alpha cuck Nutter than
nuttier than a squirrel turd Mago M
morons Maga morons let the maganga tears
flow Surfs Up ha hot and panny Pat combo
Amazon baby we're gonna go to Amazon you
know what I I'll I'll order a couple of
these hats with the with the with the
money that you guys sent today so thank
you Uncle fatty thank you Tammy and
thank you theen um we well I'll get you
I'll get some MAA or some some some um
some woke Lids that's what we'll call
them we'll call them 90s radical Save By
the Bell Taco Bell I don't know I gotta
come up with some kind of name right uh
Victor on Discord is saying I want car
window clings Tony you guys want car
window clings what like [__] them or
something you want something else I
don't know um here is um let's see what
we got here oh boy oh boy uh rats rats
in the laboratory here so uh let's see
if we
can oh boy uh-oh uh we got the petty
Yeti here's the petty why isn't it
working over here I want it to work over
here get get in that one in that one
it's not working there hang on a second
I'll bring it
up now we got a we got a picture of the
petty Yeti right
now hot fresh off the press her reaction
to me calling her a fascist here she is
PE the petty Yeti
margerie margorie hoofoot green thank
you very much and thank you to Uncle
fatty again thank you to Tammy and thank
you to theren I'll make sure to get a
couple hats today on Amazon some of them
woke
radical Lids from the 90s that deadites
[__] hate that I wear oh they [__]
hate it can you imagine you're like
you're political opinions hurt my
feelings so your hat sucks like that's
literally literally what they say your
your your political opinions hurt my
feelings when you call me a fascist it
really hurts my feelings so so you know
what your hat sucks it's so stupid your
hat a bunch of [__]
[__] Jesus now that that that tweet
that the the let me show you this here
so because I don't know if this is real
I'm not really not sure I don't know if
this is AR or what but this was posted
by Patriot takes it's usually reliable
Source I'm not going to lie usually
patri takes the reliable source but
surely this [__] [__] didn't say
that kind of [__] into a camera is she
maybe she is maybe she is oh my God
okay there you go so thanks for Patriot
takes for giving us that that piece of
content that's
beautiful beautiful piece of content
okay uh let's go back and see if we're
getting any reactions from the house
from Kevin McCarthy getting some votes
John Boehner getting some [__] you votes
and there was 22 [__] you vot what C can
you guys remember what I said how many
votes there would be eight between 18
and what was it what was 18 and
something I don't remember maybe I'm
wrong but here is here's Kevin McCarthy
talking to CNN let's see what he says
about Maga losers in the house let's see
what he says here no no no no no I get
you get I get to answer questions thank
you and so what I see though is there's
no chance in the world Democrats going
ever say again that put people before
politics they made a political decision
to try to bring chaos to shut down a
branch of government and that's wrong
you [__] [__] oh my God you notice
how they're trying really hard they're
always the victims aren't they oh my God
they're always the [__] victims this
guy and he's the biggest [__] victim
of all what a [__] ass
[__] stop being a [__] what a [__]
what a [__] that's right I'm going to
Tweet that what a [__] he
is come on
man you're mad you're [__] mad that
that that Democrats aren't voting for a
republican [__] you [__] you buddy let's
see what else do we got here um here's
Byron Donalds oh he got a vote I'm sure
what he has to say is just [__] oh
I'm sure it's brilliant let's
listen Okay a lot of these members have
complained about PR tactics not directly
from Jordan from Ser Media or or people
around that what's your response to that
do you think that those have gone too
far yeah I have I think it's not been
helpful um I don't think it's been
helpful to Jim um I know country
Americans are really passionate they
want to hear they want their voices to
be heard their voices should be heard um
but you know some of the stuff just
doesn't is not going to move these
members as a matter of fact it only it
only makes them harder to convince and
so you know my message to people you
know who are in the outside groups who
love this country they're conservative
groups their Patriots is at this point I
think everybody just needs to stop just
let the members have this this
discussion amongst usse oh they want
they want Trump to stop bullying them
well wouldn't you take it from Old Uncle
Tom Byron Donald that's right I called
him then he's a [__] an Uncle Tom [__]
Byron Donald's [__] him today yesterday
tomorrow next week [__] him [__]
Byron Donald's oh oh oh you now now you
want the [__] crazies out of your out
of your conversation oh okay we get it
now you want the [__] crazy
right-wingers out of your goddamn out of
your goddamn conversation and out of
your business hey stupid they've
controlled you forever and they'll
continue to control you you dumb son of
a [__] [__] out of here with this
nonsense there a bunch of horeshit these
people are these people are [__] dumb
as [__] and I'm not talking about the
Congress people I'm talking to people
who vote these [__] in stay the
[__] at home if you're gonna vote for
these pieces of trash stay the [__] at
home what a bunch of [__] let's see
what else do we
get uh let's see let's see if we got any
more responses here from members of the
clown
gaus oh my God what a joke what a a
[__] joke these people
are let's see now that's that's that's
an old clip I'm trying to find that
let's see if we can find a clip of a gym
I don't report sex crimes Jordan
reacting to his [__] fail here his
face plan let's see if we can get him on
on camera here uh he probably didn't did
he walk in front of the cameras at
all uh let's see I probably
not probably not I mean this would be
the face that he would make if he did
walk in front of a camera this one right
here maybe he should put his hands over
his eyes isin't that what he's good at
ah hear no evil see no evil speak no
evil oh boy oh you're being molested by
my coaching staff well that I'm not
going to tell anyone that because I'm a
piece of [__] want to make sure not to
report those sex crimes because I gotta
protect sex sex criminals what a piece
of
trash oh boy what are you going to do do
we're running out of time here I don't
know if let's see is Gabe Sanchez going
to do a second hour let's let's see if
he's got if he's got something lined up
for us today does he have a what was
that live what was that live you know
yesterday he came in right right as
right as the vote was done today they
did the vote a little little
faster you know it's it's Wednesday so
uh it should be what was that live after
right after this but we'll find out and
we'll have him send me the link if
nothing
else all right all right let's see here
oh he's just about to join us I guess I
summoned him wait wait for it wait wait
here
well maybe we've got maybe we've got do
we got we got some music here and we'll
see if we
can get um them and Gabe Sanchez is
coming in we'll see if he can we can get
his reaction to Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan being a complete [__]
loser for the second time
today the second time in a row yesterday
and today and it's not surprising that
they went to a recess because they don't
have the votes they cannot govern they
won't be able to govern so there's no
reason for them to stay in session and
keep voting because they can't because
they're worthless absolutely [__]
worthless and Derick in their
Duty let's see my sorry my computer is
lagging it's just I got so much stuff
going on here to try to keep up with
it oh boy it's been a great show today
though and I'm glad you guys joined us I
want to point something out um you know
while we're waiting on Gabe Sanchez let
me point this out to you on Theon
michaels.com I'm glad you guys joined me
today rather you like me or you like to
hate me either way I'm happy that you're
here uh the Tony michaels.com is where
you can find all the links let me show
you here if you go to the Tony
michaels.com you can see at the very top
you can subscribe once it loads you can
hit subscribe there the most current
episode is here if you want to give Live
support this is where people send in the
vinmo chats if you guys want me to buy
more hats send me a venmo super chat
right here and make sure you you
designate that it's for the the woke
Lids that I'll be buying and I'll post
pictures of the woke Lids that are on
their way also if you want to support
the show through membership you can go
to patreon.com you can follow me there
for free now there'll be some free posts
over there but if you want to become a
member that would be great to show
support for me and the show and you get
extra content like the Sunday rant and
some other things over there on patreon
and then if you want you can join the
Discord server for free as well and if
you have an Amazon Prime account you can
link it to your Twitch account that
would be great but I want to show you
this down here if you go down I got a
new section called
submissions you can submit a story to
Tony so if there's a story because I get
this a lot like people sending me
messages on Discord or whatever and they
want to submit a story for me to cover
put it here put that link here it's a
form you can fill out then if you want
to sign up to be a mod wait wait wait
wait wait I think I I think I hear
something I think I hear
[Music]
them
Wednesday it must be Cheeto chop time
Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto Cheeto
chop all
right get get the hell
out gab Sanchez what was that live he's
gonna go live here in just a few moments
give us your take so far on uh Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan losing
and face planting
again I mean it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful
morning uh it's great it's great there's
nothing better than than watching Jim
Jordan lose
two times in a row and not only two
times in a row but I was listening to an
interview from uh Buck last night and he
was like I wouldn't be surprised if Jim
Jordan lost more
votes and he did he gained two but lost
four so ended up you know I know what
was the total count was it 22 [__] Ed to
Jim Jordan it was 20 22 uh [__] you we
don't like you [__] [__] off how about
how about you go [__] yourself how about
that Jim
Jordan see you later but yeah it was uh
22 I think it was 199 or sorry 212 199
and 22 was the number so what's what are
you what are you covering today uh
besides the obvious J
Min jumping on a rake obviously Jim
Jordan stepping on the rake yeah
um I want to clear up looks like there
was some misinformation about the Gaza
bombing
yeahh try to cover that a little bit I
try to cover that a little bit and uh I
don't know see what people want to talk
about you know there's uh yeah there's a
there's a thing on V ramas Swami that
I'm going to do a longer oh yeah are you
talking about the speech that she gave
the speech that the or the question that
they asked the question
good I'm gonna be on the I'm gonna be on
the side of people it wasn't really a
question but it was it's an absolute
must-watch you have to watch her destroy
vet I mean she to the question at the
very end
yeah but yeah and she destroyed him it
was great it was great it was great get
over there cover that [__] get the hell
out of here get the hell out of here
everybody Gabe Sanchez what was that
live right after the Tony Michels
podcast here on YouTube do not forget to
hit the Subscribe button right now here
on YouTube you can also be on Twitch if
you're on Twitch it'll go I'm gonna do a
raid on Twitch go to twitch.tv Michaels
it'll go directly there if you're on
Facebook I'm glad you follow us on
Facebook but if you're on Facebook
you're going to have to go over to
YouTube or twitch to watch what was that
live with Gabe Sanchez I'm glad you
joined me here today same time same
place tomorrow Sur up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
that